rated E for Everyone fruit should be
allowed to rest in peace picked up with
her she's like a fruit grave-robber
no one knew her as Maggie Friedman till
the world she was funny the fruit ninja
hey my son no crust she didn't break
fruit ninja records she obliterated them
and words read fast hey you're not
supposed to be in here high schooler
subarashii Brenda oh also could you
please cut in half our minds finish it
later
fruit ninja people like that shouldn't
be allowed to walk the streets because
someone has to clean that up and that
someone is me here we are at the house
of the so called
fruit ninja where 16 year old Maddie
Friedman has been making quite the name
for herself but she's still no jesper
[Music]
he made Maddie look like that unibrow in
the turtleneck huh
legend has it just as pants were killed
in a freak mango accident actually guys
I'm with a justice challenge surprised
nobody really as good as Maddie Freedman
jesper mad you me battle mode
you want to be the fruit ninja the only
fruit ninja
I'm not even Japanese Maddie I assume
you've heard Jasper's challenge do you
have a response
yeah sure Your Honor this was no
ordinary fruit ninja battle mode this
was the real deal real pineapple real
bananas insults
[Music]
okay
sensei you wanna talk to me just yoga
anything in the second pass
run in the place
we're not getting these swords anymore
[ __ ]
only on Xbox one